okay
what the [ __ ] did what did the punisher
say mark
i don't know i was hearing jt tell the
story
tell us jc what did you say what was it
jc what did the [ __ ] punisher say man
i looked down the barrel of the camera
and said
well don't whatever you do
he was uh god i lost everything sorry
everybody the power went out in my
neighborhood
um is so funny coming back
into this uh he looked down the barrel
of the lens and said if you have a
job that is getting in the way of your
passion quit it because passion will
find a way
uh i quit that job two weeks later
uh i wrote a short film called hughes
the force
and then uh six months after i wrote
that short film
i started working with kevin doing jay
and simon bob get old in hollywood
babylon
so uh i'm an example of passion finds a
way
because that was you you're you're
someone who got saved by the punisher
yeah i did get saved by the punisher
i was about to say if you have abs like
that then sure you can do all kinds of
stuff
now there's a guy who takes his shirt
off at the [ __ ] beach
there's a dude takes a shirt off at
comic-con like i was literally at a bar
and thomas jane rolled up and just like
[ __ ] magnum pi opened up his shirt
and just starts like stroking his abs
because if i had abs like that i would
also just play with him like a xylophone
the man was the star of a tv show called
hung
volume plus we got in the news we're
glad everybody's back with us in chat
thanks for
for being patient and hanging in there
and stuff yeah and like we didn't even
like
play a trailer with a song in it or
nothing i know we weren't canceled
because [ __ ] on youtube
natural causes he is working on battery
power at his house
he's using everything to heat those
bottles and so
one more stream what uh what else we got
the last news item for the day is that
we were
so close to the end of the show so close
to the end
what is the last news item of the day
the last news item of the day is last
week we talked about
how black lightning was spinning off uh
painkiller
um into hopefully his own show there's
gonna be an episode sure it's fine
that that uh black lightning is here to
stay
indeed anywhere of the cw
slate and and [ __ ] a robust indicator
of health and longevity
i mean they didn't cancel happy days
when laverne and shirley got spun off
nope uh but they're canceling black
lightning
what uh the cw confirmed that the
superhero drama will end with the
upcoming fourth season which is set to
premiere early next year
um um you know did you ever go deep on
it
i never went that deep on it man i never
went that deep on it and i think
you know part of my i guess resistance
to it like and i liked i
watched most of the first season and i
liked it but it seemed
clear that that they were never really
going to play
in the dc universe or the berlanti verse
at large
except for the one crossover episode
they had done and it was like it was
great to see black lightning interfacing
with the flash and and those other
characters
but because it was so siloed off it just
i don't know like i didn't quite it
didn't connect with me the way i hoped
it would
um you know i appreciate what they were
going for i appreciate what they
managed to pull off i mean it was the
first dc superhero series for the black
lead
you know and and but it's the second one
to end
it's to announce the ending of its run
this season along with supergirl
someone else on uh in the chat that's
their name
someone else that i really enjoyed the
first two seasons of black lightning the
third season
nope damn someone else
um yeah so then there's somebody who
actually watched though yeah
um well the show's gonna live on
through what is it called painkiller
painkiller yes so a lot of the dna
of black lightning will exist it
wouldn't surprise me at all of some of
those characters
also managed to to slip over um but uh
but yeah it's a it's a slightly sad day
um or i guess it will be a sad day
later this year when you get to the
actual series finale of black lightning
but
for now at least we know it's coming
um yeah it's uh
well it got a chance how many seasons
was that
uh the fourth season is coming up so
it's you know
that's a really good run for a superhero
show
in this in this here economy um four
seasons is nothing to shake a stick
at it's no 15 seasons that supernatural
went or whatever
uh supernatural just ended last week
right it just ended last week i
i dvr'ed the finale a lot of
consternation hold on
sean wilson asked are you buying into
the theory
that jeff bridges character in iron man
was controlled by thanos using
loki's staff not at all where is that a
theory rolling around online
that that that sounds like some q and on
[ __ ] right there
and i don't understand like sounds like
somebody really trying to like tie it
all back to
thanos ain't nothing wrong with uh iron
monger just being a dick
you don't have to be controlled by outer
space
you know he tried to kill tony stark
like
before he was even iron man he tried to
have him killed in the desert and stuff
so yeah
i don't think that's like a mine stone
obadiah's stain was just a
yeah he's just greedy yeah he's greedy
[ __ ] man
classic villain don't have to be like
some overlord from space
puppet master and i'm just a greedy
american prick who wanted morge
tony stark built this in a cave with a
bunch of rocks
he's so good in that movie um
yeah man i didn't see that there anyway
back to what we were just talking yeah
supernatural
i dvr the finale even though i've never
seen a single episode of supernatural so
i look forward to watching it and being
utterly confused
i saw a bunch of folks on twitter who
were hardcore
fans of the show were like
not you know they ranked the [ __ ]
finale next to game of thrones and stuff
uh a lot of complaining i saw more
complaining about the end of the show
than i saw like yay um
and i guess one of the stars in advance
had kind of been like you know when i
first read the finale script
i didn't like it reached out to kripke
who created the show eric quick be the
guy who does uh
the boys who is now and you know they
talk through it and he goes and then i
started to like it
so that night when supernatural finale
aired a bunch of people
were like they kept retweeting that clip
because i guess he was at some kind of
supernatural con talking
episode and they were like we know you
were trying to soften this up for
like this this is an outrage blah blah
blah
so uh i don't know anybody uh
watch the finale in uh
chat i'm looking at you right now i
never got the impression we had a bunch
of uh supernatural
um fans kripke defended it langley nealy
said the [ __ ] key defense season finale
he had nothing to do with it but he did
defend it
uh we got uh legal land
13 says i watched it i hated it
um uh matt moscow
datsuko says i watch supernatural
um
hunt on my wayward sons i think it was
carry-on
jensen ackles that's his name jensen
ackles lass raw says jensen ackles
didn't like it
uh bill h says my girlfriend cried kurt
adams says the finale was just mediocre
not terrible
um uh adam
gavosk goveski says supernatural should
have ended season five
wow damn did you ever watch much of it
i never saw any of it i i tried tuning
in
like it was season eight or nine you
know when it when it
when it starts to take pick up some
steam i was like well let me see what
the supernatural thing is all about
i watched half an episode and just was
lost by it
um and like the tone was a little weird
um
in ways that i couldn't put a finger on
like
i don't know it was an acting style
maybe it was a directorial style
whatever it was just didn't quite engage
me um and so yeah i never i never
watched it
sean cisco's a big fan it was a good
ending kev
um and then uh um
wolfy 23 says i did and i liked it
uh and then vanessa martinez says the
finale was
trash though
yeah almost you know we're always like
man i want a [ __ ] show how come we
don't get a show
i'm almost glad we don't get a show
because even if you get a show and then
you try to end the show people like
[ __ ] suck you guys suck this show
sucks
yeah cuz last season blows stratus
strong says i watched and cried like a
baby
good for you yeah man [ __ ] a
ice donkey says daughter was a big fan
and was super disappointed uh bobby
jackson says it was more of an
epilogue this ep the fb4 was more of a
finale i'd heard that but the
episode before the season finale like
jensen echols says that's more of our
finale i think that blog they did i
think a flash forward where
people got old and you got to see how
people died and stuff
yeah little six feet under ending a
little bit god that was a fantastic
ending that ending still makes me cry
yeah
um all right but what will we talk about
before we delve into
supernatural yeah the end of uh black
lightning
yeah the end of black lightning uh so
they're losing black lightning this
season after this season it's over
yeah the the upcoming fourth season is
the last and then
supergirl leaves this year as well
indeed
but we know we have lois and clark or
whatever they're super yeah superman and
lois we know we'll have batwoman
um legends of tomorrow is still kicking
um
and flash is still happening flash is
still happening
um i wonder when they're gonna announce
that how many seasons they on
i think it's six maybe what did arrow do
seven and again i went seven like a
truncated seventh season or maybe a
truncated eighth season i can't remember
exactly if flash will get roughly the
same run or just one more
we went one more
well and then they just announced
there's going to be a wonder girl
show or at least a pilot on cw right
yeah i mean they they have some stuff in
the offing they have some some ways to
help
um build out that universe but yeah
they're they're losing some big guns
some folks are you know crapping on them
but you got to remember it's kind of
like i'm looking in the chat it's kind
of like uh
you know right now marvel cinematic
universe has gone through some
growth and changes and you're about to
not see some people that you're always
used to seeing and you're about to see a
whole bunch of new kids that
you've never seen before who hopefully
take us all through the next phase
and stuff like that so it stands to
reason that on cw
you know a lot of these shows been going
as long as they have
looks like they're trying to shake it up
but it doesn't sound like they're moving
away from superheroes they know they've
got
their bread buttered there with that
yeah not that berlanti verse or you know
arrowverse or whatever um why let that
go
never-ending treasure trove of dc
characters to choose from with only very
few that you're not allowed to play with
on a regular basis so it feels like they
could fill those
same slots brand new cw shows all the
time and it doesn't seem like it's like
remember when riverdale happened it
looked like oh [ __ ] now it's all going
to be this
but riverdale is still happening but the
other one remember did katie keem a
spin-off
that's right went away sabrina got
finished over at netflix and stuff so it
feels like if cw is going to lean in any
direction it's probably going to be more
superheroes
yeah you know and they also still have
star girl we forgot about star girl
um yeah which is huge jason news
literally every time i see him he's like
you're watching star girl i was like
you want you asked me that every [ __ ]
time and every time i've told you yes
leave me alone favorite [ __ ] show
and you know he's become a big fan of
the jsa and stuff because he's nice
um but yeah you're right i don't think
superheroes are going anywhere i just
think that it's
like any good franchise it's in a bit of
a rebuilding phase
um where it's got to get in some new
players it's got to do some time to
build up its team again and then make
another run for the championship
um and that's fine that's that's the the
order of things
uh wolf and kitten mysticism says did
you not even mention batwoman in this
group oh do not even mention batwoman in
this group
um why i did i did though but yeah we
should that's part of the part of the
show
part of the lansing verse yeah for sure
um um but yeah man that's the news
somebody said uh who is it here uber
co says dc tv seems like it peaked
on the last crossover um well let's be
honest that last crossover crisis was
so [ __ ] big but yeah especially for
like tv
um but uh you know
i don't know they peaked i think you
could go again you could do other cool
things
but it feels like like you know
to some degree they did it everyone saw
how [ __ ] excited fandom got with
crisis
and then big dc like the movies were
like all right we'll do that and that's
what [ __ ] flash is
it's like look now look michael keaton's
gonna be in this [ __ ] which is
something they wanted to do in that
crisis first
yeah i get the feeling that that crisis
was to the dc
berlanti verse what endgame was to the
mcu
and that there's going to be more
they're going to find new ways to cross
these characters over but it's going to
be a stretch before it becomes this
giant all hands on deck
um you know just locker room clearing
uh event that way because it's also
super hard to do
you know and it's logistically it's a
nightmare
and i think that at some point you know
you want to be able to tell some more
intimate stories
about these characters crossing over
that don't have to involve everybody in
the end of the world
and just hey what if it was just you
know a superman flash story
let's do that wouldn't that be great
pathetic pixels asks
weren't you doing baku banzai
um still in
still or when i can say something about
that
um let's see um
do you want to just go to q a or we just
we are q
a and now apparently ricky meru og says
can we get kevin smith to play condiment
man in cw
[ __ ] yeah what a good idea make me the
condiment king not condiment man
condiment king man
i've directed enough and let's be honest
most people are like meh
but like i'm now interested in being in
[ __ ] man especially like these
day pop-up parts where you don't have to
be there the whole [ __ ] time
i like that you've gone the inverse of
orson welles
like orson welles decided to give up on
directing and gain 500 pounds
and you're like you know what i'm gonna
shed all this weight and just start
acting
he started selling wine though i started
smelling weed like last year or so
yeah but it was awesome and this is
parmesan wine it's the finest wine that
anyone could drink bad idea [ __ ]
made like one of the greatest movies
ever made
and he made lots more after that well
it's not like he made citizen kane and
stop
but like you could have because the
movie is [ __ ] great and stuff like
that
um all right yeah jc join us jc i'm sure
you got some questions i'm
reading the chat as well all right i've
got a few questions i wanted to give a
shout out to
um all of the people watching the show
that
uh hooked jocelyn me and jen up
with uh gifts so carrie sauer george
mcgowan susan horn
joanne smith fiona lewis john steven
josh john matthews
marcelo yoshida kyle matthews michelle
matlin
jack e legg ii josephine nguyen sophia l
dustin lowry cassie banks jeff kenneth
murray chris roberson
robinson sean mccarthy nathan gonzalez
oh dark nate and jason paul
murslack melinda barr james walker the
second
and uh bryce benton all sent
a little presents for my baby so thank
you guys
i got a present for you baby
maybe you can't play with it but this
will look great in the nursery
yeah you got to baby proof those ears
man no doubt man those are not
i will uh next time i see you i got a
cash gift for that kid
ooh college fund or
you tell the kid one day that i gave her
the money but you spend it now
um of age to know what money is we
probably would have
done away with money it'll be like star
trek
that's right they got a money in star
trek right yeah no money
nobody has jobs is that always part of
the show like even in the first series
like did they ever call attention to it
like hey man you got you got a five
bucks and he's like no man it's star
trek
um they didn't until next generation i
don't think that the
the first series the the classic series
ever really bothered with it
but on tos and it was always when like
some time travel dude would show up
back into from the past and to the
present um and would be like hey man so
i'm gonna do this i'm gonna get a bunch
of money it's like but there's no money
here
like we've got pockets on our pants like
we just
we we pursue the things that encourage
us and and society manages to to
derive some semblance of advancement
because of it but there's no more
poverty there's no more greed there's no
more hunger we've eradicated everything
um yeah so that
yeah for your kid [ __ ] it we'll do that
jc
yeah not for anybody else's kids but for
your kids you picked the questions
okay uh alex semi says
um if you could stop kovid from ever
existing
but it would mean you could never
consume any media from marvel
star wars or dc which one would you
choose and why
so you could stop kovid but you had to
give up star wars marvel or dc
which one i
have to give up what already exists or
is it further stuff
i think you would never have gotten the
mcu or you would have never gotten star
wars
comics the whole the whole thing would
just be
lifted out of existence
um well let's be honest like
we'd get rid of all of them if it would
get rid of
[ __ ] covet but we're only being asked
to get rid of one this is one of those
internet like
you can keep three or whatever one of
these must go
yes like a twisted version of like [ __ ]
married kid
right um
marvel delights me on such a regular
basis that like
in a world where i did not have to give
it up for a coveted cure
i would definitely not voluntarily do
that
uh that leaves star wars and
dc and right now you know if you'd asked
me pre-mandalorian i'd be like well i
guess we've had enough star wars but
now they're [ __ ] nailing star wars
perfecting star wars so i don't want to
see that go
yeah man i guess i back process of
elimination and again this is a fantasy
so i don't want to read some article on
comicbook.com
that says kevin smith hates dc but i
would
i'm i'm that would be the one that i
would i'd give up for coven
yeah i mean i think that batman would
understand that batman would want if
that
he would you know sometimes you got to
do the hard thing
um yeah i think if if the question is if
the if the problem being posed
is you never got to have one of these
not even like i just don't get any more
but you're you're mortgaging its very
existence in exchange for
no covet um i don't think i would want i
wouldn't be the person i am if there
hadn't been a star wars like star wars
is my introduction to fantasy and
science fiction and genre
i couldn't give that one up um i think
you know mcu and by extension marvel
comics were my first superheroes that i
really got into
so i think i'm kind of with you that
like you know the
the dc cinematic universe or whatever
we're calling it and
television for that matter
doesn't have the same hold on me the way
marvel or star wars does
so yes i'm sure that somebody will
interpret this as
more confirmation that i that i actively
dislike dc comics and
oh believe me i'm getting kicked in the
teeth in chat for this
kevin kevin says like kevin to time
warner
uh you shouldn't exist or something like
that yeah go kick rocks
they're not sleepy what are they now
warner
and warner media we've seen them go
through
it was warner brothers when we were kids
then at one point it became time warner
for a long time
and then it became time warner aol
remember that aol aol time warner
because aol
they went first could you imagine there
was a point where aol went first
and now it's just warner media yeah yeah
just warner media
um and we didn't even mention the other
day like a financial article that
suggested warner media and universal
like what do they call it when they
combine
merge yeah that would make them
a [ __ ] entertainment powerhouse titan
the size of
disney if you put yeah i mean at some
point there will only be one company
so it's just a matter of time which
makes me so mad enough for the reason
that it should everyone's like it should
make you mad because there'll be less
places to make your entertainment stuff
like that
but it makes me mad because a long time
ago i wanted to make a
clerks cartoon movie where um
uh there was uh a like
basically the name of the studio
that existed was the combination
of every studio's name because they'd
all become one gigantic
[ __ ] stuff and i was i would have
been
right for heaven's sakes like it would
have seemed like a goofy joke had we
done it but i would have been right
it would have been some simpsons level
prognostication that's true could you
imagine be that good that you could
predict the future
while making people laugh totally yeah
we
see we have forgot to mention however
that uh that a batman statue went up in
burbank we didn't even talk about that
we did um this look number one
it's a jim lee looking bronze statue
so [ __ ] my hats off to it uh
i can't wait to see it take a picture
with it and stuff
um it was bought we got got to say right
up front but
paid for by the city of burbank so
dc warner brothers they did not pay for
this at all
um but it does go up shortly after a
bunch of layoffs which
no upset a lot of people online a bunch
of people are like
the optics of this are not good but look
i mean yes
i understand the optics of this are not
good that being said look at that statue
come on man they're finally making
statues
to [ __ ] we care about dude like never
mind
like [ __ ] who's that on the horse
some [ __ ] fought in a war
now we're getting the statues we deserve
our real heroes the dark knight the dark
knight you get there's [ __ ] detroit
still trying to do a robocop statue
or that like the wolverine statue that
should exist up in canada
no stuff yeah it's for all of our heroes
the heroes we can all
identify i mean they're not the rocky
statue forever
no and not controversial nobody's ever
going to be like take that batman statue
down you can me batman stands for
justice
and everyone loves batman um yeah i'm
more i'm all for this
more more statues everywhere
of characters that we can get behind
yes less confederate generals and more
superheroes that should be a no-brainer
but yeah
absolutely but i'm saying less like you
know
of the of the non-confederate the
union's the winners
american
never mind those cats either just batman
look
where's the robin statue what's right
next door to burbank
glendale with a robin statue right there
there you go cape crusader cities
yeah that statue looks [ __ ] dope man
yeah they're
they're a captain america's statue in
brooklyn i don't know why there isn't
but yes isn't there a captain america
statue somewhere
is there tell us internet if there is a
captain america statue in brooklyn
because if there isn't
marvel is just leaving money on the
table somebody just said there is a
captain america statue in brooklyn
somebody said stanley statue in new york
yes cisco lopez
where's the [ __ ] stan lee statue in
new york man
yeah outside of like the original marvel
hq there should be a stanley statue
standing on a [ __ ] a brass stop a
soapbox
that would be great um all right jc give
us another one
um i like this one goddammit russ was
asking what fictional character and band
would you have post
and guest on saturday night live
what fictional character and band
does the band have to be fictional also
a fictional band
fictional host so wow i just want to say
question of the night outstanding
fantastic what a great imagination host
tony stark
fair come on he'd be so charming
um and banned
the hong kong cavaliers oh
nice one thank you nice one all right
now
my host [ __ ] fictional character
is the host of saturn live
um
i want to say the joker don't do that we
saw what happens when he's on a show
yeah but everybody dies when it's the
joker yes
um okay
um someone said but could tony stark
act i mean not everyone who
hosts as much as any athlete who shows
up
um miss piggy
as the host as the host um
and uh josie and the pussycats are the
fictional band
look at you [ __ ] very female heavy
slave jose the pussycats
excellent [ __ ] choice um we could
throw i'd throw in for
if we couldn't get the hong kong
cavaliers because buck rubanza was off
on a mission
then i would suggest um who was my
backup fan
um [ __ ] ellen aim and the rockers oh
the attackers the attackers yes oh that
was also i was
debating illinois and tigers but good
job what it means to be young mark
uh what a great question some of that
but uh yeah that's those are good
[ __ ] choices outstanding and i like
that question
well done uh all right jc all right last
one from evan bernstein
uh says my partner and i bonded a ton
over the mcu during quarantine
what show or movies did you guys bond
over with your partner and family during
quarantine
great question i think like the rest of
the world i bonded with my wife over
tiger king
i watched it and then like i watched it
by myself because she had no interest
she's like i don't you know she
likes the animals mistreated and i was
like well
other than the general mistreatment of
like nobody seems to give a [ __ ] about
these animals as much as they give a
[ __ ] about their own fame
you're not going to see too much like
you but you've got to watch it because
it's just so [ __ ] mind-bending
and so i watched it and then literally
the next day
i rewatched it with her and
binged it and stuff um uh so we bonded
kind of over that
um recently with the crown
uh we've been watching the [ __ ] out of
that um
what was the spanish uh
bank heist thing oh right like money
not money heist but it was was it money
housed it was like the poorly titled
monkey
the spanish title was the house of paper
casa de papel that was [ __ ] a
fantastic watch
four seasons worth of something to dive
into jamie cadier's keeps urging us to
watch uh
um you know uh queen's gambit
no no i wish i watched which was great
didn't you watch it
and you were suggesting it like
i watched that like after you mentioned
it i was
uh here and i was like you know mark
said queen's game
is good and i started rolling it and
[ __ ] and i thought she would dig it up
with me but she was doing other [ __ ]
never fell in so [ __ ] good
yeah like an easy spell to get cast who
knew
that like that was gonna be up my alley
you're gonna love this thing with uh
about like this girl chess player who
takes pills like crazy i'd be like i
don't know that sounds more like my
wife's done
but i [ __ ] loved it the guy who
worked on it
was his name scott frank scott frank
yeah he did uh like
[ __ ] out of sight and and gets
ocean's 11. i think he wrote that
yeah dudes uh he's got legit like chops
he's a
a soderberg guy um but man this thing
was wonderful but it's based on a book
yeah based on a fictional book that i
think he wrote and directed
every episode of so yeah i saw that man
good for you scott frank
really good really enjoyable um
it's uh yeah it reminded me of uh
like first in the beginning i was like
oh this reminds me of
uh you know the movie we were talking
about searching for bobby fischer
just by virtue of the fact that oh chess
and chess while being
the spine of the [ __ ] thing you know
you don't have to understand
jack [ __ ] about chess to enjoy that
[ __ ] series
yeah it's so good so good um i
i did walking dead early on [ __ ] 10
seasons of walking dead or whatever
however many there are
um now the the missus and i
are slowly we're trying to portion out
the rest of shit's creek
um zary severino jr says scott frank
also wrote mangold's logan i didn't know
that
yeah i think he did that's a great
script yeah
i think you know he was maybe first on
and then michael green um came
afterwards that's right he worked on it
as well
yeah um but yeah so shit's creek where
we're like watching an episode at night
as opposed to five episodes a night
which you could do easily because it
goes down so easy
um and then with uh with my son we've
been watching fresh prince of bel-air
which is a surprisingly endurable show
i expected it to feel crazy dated and
occasionally when you know some of the
references
you know it's like oh hey belle biv
devoe are in this episode and the
audience is going nuts and my son's like
who's that
and i'm like it's spellbiv to vote kid
yeah it's like i'd still go nuts if they
showed up in an episode
yeah that girl is poisoned don't you
just say
that's bell biv devoe now you know
he's like i can't blow anywhere i live
here like oh the other room your lady
was like
she's driving me
uh so yeah those have been the big sort
of quarantine binges
um i've slowly by myself been going
through
a new girl um just because i
i remain enchanted by jake johnson um
you know the one true peter b parker um
and so yeah but that's been it and
that's been and it's been
grand uh and yet there are still [ __ ]
things that i feel like i should watch
and haven't watched
um because there's just so much um
heckler hello heckler is asking for a
shout out early on
um the uh
you know what's coming this week today
is monday
that means we only have to wait 24 48
96 hours before we get to see
the live-action debut of ahsoka tano
i know friday day after thanksgiving we
will all be thankful
thursday night man don't go to sleep
12-1
get i'm gonna be on twitter spoiling it
for everybody taking screen shots
it's gonna make people go [ __ ] mad
i um yeah man it's gonna be
pretty damn cool uh we're probably gonna
see a lightsaber fight
in this episode dark saber on a light on
lightsaber
i hope so i hope so if there's one thing
mandalorian has been lacking
it's lightsaber fights truly
all right we got one more question in
the hopper no i think that was we hit
three
was that three for the first round if
you want man because you gotta if you go
you bowl the strike you get one more
spare if you like
i just now i thought that i want apollo
creed to host
snl apollo creed
yeah that's your re that's your rebuy
that's my rebuy my rebuy is that one
apollo creek
does he wear uh does he open with a
living in america
i mean is the is the musical guest james
brown
who is fictional enough
because in the movie he [ __ ] counts
uh carl weathers did that last episode
of uh
of uh mandalorian yeah and you know like
that dude has been like a stealth tv
directing mainstay for like a decade
if not more did we talk so when was the
last time we did the show um
a week ago i think we could before the
last episode of mandalorian
yes before his episode that episode i
felt was the most
star wars-y of the episodes i've seen so
far might have had something to do with
like
all the star wars ephemera a lot of
storm troopers a lot of
imperial hallways a lot of uh speeder
bikes and [ __ ] like that
yeah but uh he i thought he did a great
job i mean why wouldn't this guy's been
on sets forever and [ __ ] no totally
yeah it uh it was definitely i mean it
was that one and the bryce dallas howard
one
that had come the week before um we're
both
like directed with sure hands and you're
100 on board with what's happening and
it's all clear
and high adventure and not so mythology
based and just like this is
this is what's happening right now it
doesn't you know the event the mythology
always
kind of gets put to the side so they can
confront whatever
the episode adventure happens to be and
stuff
then they pick it back up and keep kind
of moving forward
right i haven't been impatient or
like oh [ __ ] this planet would you get
to ahsoka or something like that like
every week i'm happy to see
where they go but i've never seen a
poorly directed episode they're all
directed really well
um in this episode you see in the
background they had an ig-11 statue
i did and remember last week i was like
there was a picture of the [ __ ] yoda
figure
that spoils the kid's name the child's
name
it was not spoiling the kid's name it
said
the child and in parentheses it said
navarro that's the name of the planet
so that version of the child is
from navarro not from like i guess
they'll do
alternate versions of the child figure
and stuff right
so the kid's name ain't navarro the
planet's name is tomorrow it's nice
big big reveal with uh
uh what is the the gina ladies name the
one that everyone's mad at
cara dune hair dude she [ __ ] i don't
they didn't say that before that she was
from all around did they
no i mean i think they they mentioned
that she clearly was a was a
soldier for the rebellion drop trooper
who had been
sort of disenchanted with um
with the entire scenario post post
alderaan
post yap and post all of that [ __ ] um
but yeah now a lot of information about
her we got to see [ __ ] moth getting
again
you know more about the dark saber more
about their
plans for what they were doing with the
the child's blood
trying to create a apparently a [ __ ]
unit full of genetically enhanced
soldiers
that they just needed more blood dark
troopers or something
and then also it just opened with like
if you put the red wire
where the blue wire
which is absolutely adorable i'm seeing
baby yoda in school
stealing cookies thanks macaroons they
could do no wrong with that
[ __ ] character man like so damn good
yeah it was a joy to watch
and you know i was like oh man there was
no ending
of like there she is or something like
that but why would they
because the guy who created the
character is gonna be responsible for
her live-action debut from first
to last it's not like oh she technically
debuted here and then dave directed this
episode
bam it's all in her episode that's kind
of sweet
when life circles back like that that
guy
never in a million years thought that
one day he'd be directing
an episode of a star wars show that a
character he created for a cartoon
was in it's got to be satisfying i mean
it happened to him a while ago
we're singing it this week but it's got
to be amazing it's an
amazing feeling for him yeah uh
i can't imagine it but also good for him
man
good for him very good yeah believe me
it's uh especially look good for anybody
that [ __ ]
knocks it out the park like you know
it's tough
in this business because sometimes you
look at others succeeding and you're
like man why
not me because we're all children in
this business that's a childish [ __ ]
thought
but i never feel that way about [ __ ]
that i love like i never feel like about
any of the marvel directors or [ __ ]
kevin feige i'm never like man why not
me i'm like no keep doing it that's good
that's good same with [ __ ] everything
going on in the mandalorian man i'm like
go go you got this yeah this is amazing
[ __ ] you need no help [ __ ] this is
fantastic
um yeah except i would like to be on it
amazing as long as i have to take my
shirt off to circle way back to the
[ __ ] beginning
bring it all back um
there it is folks we did a [ __ ] show
me mark jc [ __ ] baby yoda
yeah baby dave navarro uh baby navarro
did you like that show if you did um you
got to thank jc
for making time from his busy baby
rearing schedule which sounds [ __ ]
nasty
um raising baby he's got his own baby
yoda man he's [ __ ] the mandalorian
right now
one man and a baby and a and a girl he's
got a partner as well yes
um so uh thanks to jc for making this uh
happen
but there is no show without that guy
who's down in that box right there
um give it up for mr mark bernard and
everybody oh
thank you very much thank you very much
uh
is fat man batman on batman
that is gonna be uh fat man beyond for
this week
until uh next week ladies and gentlemen
uh i am kevin smith i am mark bernardin
tune in next time same fat time same
fat channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
kevinsmith this is the way happy
thanksgiving
yeah that too
you